well i don't see moon knight behind you
what's going on here but i am wearing a
moon shirt i do see that that's pretty
dope my friend awesome awesome
there's no listen there's no uh moon
night cool collectibles yet uh but that
will happen soon they're coming they're
coming i think i think what's gonna be
on the shelf soon is gonna be really
exciting
i i am confident i like the
the ridiculous stuff but anyway um do
you think that moon knight i think um
that some of the characters of the mcu
it's it's good that they happened later
in the development of the mcu because
the audience is primed for
like you know further kind of things um
do you think moon knight could have
happened before this or do you think
moon knight is a result of everything
that's happened previously
hey with the genius of kevin feige moon
knight could have been the first one out
of the gates so that guy can do anything
he's an incredible storyteller what i do
agree with you on
i do think this was a character that
is able to
um kind of go in the wake of some of the
rest of the mcu but also i think
really the time why the time was right
for this is really also the disney plus
platform this is such a complex
character to have a platform where you
get
multiple episodes five hours six hours
to tell this complex story i think
that's what we needed more than anything
i think we needed a broader
a broader canvas that took this much
time to present itself more than
anything
yeah one of the things about moon knight
that i like is some of the mcu series
are a little shorter and these episodes
are actually like 50 minutes yeah i
don't know how the last two are but um
can you sort of talk about that these
are um you really pushed it for the six
episodes
we did i mean you know um from what you
know about this amazing character that
goes back to 1975 and and werewolf by
night and then 1980 for his own series
over the years over the decades there's
so many complex story lines that we were
able to choose from so many complex
themes to choose from that we really had
trouble containing ourselves to you know
45 minutes give or take per episode
because what the what the writers and
the um pencilers and the and the artists
were able to do over the years was
mesmerized and entertaining and it
presented a very rich complex character
and the real challenge of this was not
what to add but sadly what was
you know what to take away and the
beauty of that is all that stuff still
remains and then some with this
character that i think the fans i think
are going to enjoy this ride that we
take them on and they're going to want
to see more
during the development process of the
show i always am curious about what
almost happened so what almost happened
with this show was it ever a radically
different storyline did you ever almost
go in a different you know what i mean a
different direction
absolutely you know i i don't know
the right almost happened i can tell you
this i can tell you why this story
happened because we were in the writers
room and we've been developing for a
while with the great jeremy slater and
the team of writers that we had in the
room and we were coming up with some
really good ideas and we were having um
some solid
narratives that were really exciting us
but we hadn't found it yet um and i was
in the kitchen at the mo at marvel
studios
and kevin came in he asked me how's it
going um how's the story going i kind of
told him i said we're getting there
we're getting there we're still looking
for certain aspects he said hey i
absolutely remember being a kid in
brooklyn and my parents putting me on a
train into manhattan and standing in
line in a line that wrapped around the
block as i was waiting to get into the
latest egyptian art exhibit that was
going through the country and he said
you know the excitement i felt standing
there in line and then how mesmerized i
was by the art and the architecture once
i got inside he said if we can grab on
to that excitement i found as a kid with
all those egyptology aspects and just
the natural globetrotting narrative that
moon knight has and specifically his
origin story if we can lean into that
we have a series that will span 45
minutes an episode and um that really
was our north star from then on and so
it's really not about the
um what we lost it's just what we gained
and what truly gave us the fuel in the
narrative engines and that was one of
the days you know you have various touch
points i mean you've been in similar
situations there's various touch points
but that was a day that we really found
the fuel that would be our fire to this
day
yeah this kevin feige guy i think he's
gonna have a career i think he's gonna
be all right yeah yeah he's kinda you
know he's kind of okay um
i'm just
he's so good i don't think people
realize though like
like what he's done is impossible
in terms of the mcu it's truly
impossible and like it's notes like this
as to why he's who he is
no you know you know it's not only um in
the mcu i mean you gotta look at the
broader film
um you know art and what he's doing and
what the rest of the team at marvel
studios is doing is truly remarkable and
i don't know if it'll ever be replicated
i can't imagine a scenario in which it
will be it's it's mesmerizing and it's
honored to be part of that team but uh
it's an incredible team i got to tell
you
yeah
absolutely um for soon to be fans of the
series uh is there anything that you
think they might be surprised to learn
about the actual making of moon knight
you know we had such a great production
design team
um
you feel like you're everywhere at once
you know we can't step into every um
location and actually be there but you
know to tell fans that we told this
globetrotted adventure and we did go to
london we did go to obviously we shot in
budapest and we were in slovenia and we
were in jordan and wadi rum and the
acaba desert um
just to tell the fans that yeah the vast
majority of this is shot in budapest
i don't think it'll blow their minds
people know um the value of an
incredible production designer and green
screen and everything else but just to
see
this story told on the world stage
pretty cool
also i'm listen i watch a lot of stuff
uh the some of the sets that they built
for this
really looked incredible i like they
looked beyond what you would expect yeah
i'll tell you this story i can't
unfortunately tell you the set's name
because it is a spoiler but i was
standing there with ethan hawk on this
day of filming and this was well into
halfway filming um and he was just
sitting there looking around and he just
leaned over to me and said man i've been
doing this for 30 years give or take and
every day i continue to walk on these
sets and my mind is blown so you're
talking about a storyteller and ethan is
at the top of his game both in front of
the camera and behind the camera who
steps onto these sets and he's seeing
stuff he's never seen before and that
artistry and craftsmanship that goes
with it um i think that tells you the
level at which stephania cella and the
rest of our department heads were
playing and it was it was amazing yeah
no it looks incredible on screen have to
ask you um i know this is going to be a
big hit with audiences
uh and i know you'll be guarded with
this answer but have you guys talked
about
like the future of moon knight in terms
of could there be a season two because
some of the mcu shows aren't are doing a
season two yeah and believe me you're
smart enough you already know part of my
answer it's a great question for kevin
but what i will say is this because we
delve into so many interesting tones in
the tapestry we eventually weave
together with this show
the action adventure globe trotting the
bump in the night horror aspects of it
the mental health character study the
humor
i do think wherever kevin wants this
character go in the future i don't think
there's any corner in the mcu that that
moon knight cannot inhabit naturally um
and that is a testament not only to the
character on the page but the character
that oscar isaac brings to brings to the
screen
i definitely want to ask you this if you
you obviously making the first season of
any show is a huge eye-opening
experience and what you learned during
the making what did you learn making the
first season that if you were to make a
second season you would take with you i
would take this amazing cast with me and
if it can't be this cast in the future
people um and artists men and crafts
women
who are at the top of their game just
like oscar ethan and may are um that
makes my job so much easier when these
actors and you know i i gotta say this
too i don't look at oscar and may or
ethan as actors i look at them as
storytellers and the paintbrush they
paint with is acting um the dedication
they brought to this was just
invigorating and it helped you know
after being on this show for well over a
year and a half by the time they came
aboard i needed that that b12 shot and
they brought it so that's what i would
really take with me i would take this
cast and if it can't be this particular
cast um one that brings the same
dedication to it and obviously that
dedication on the director's end as well
um it just makes my life so much easier
uh that's what i would take with me
on that note i gotta stop uh it is
always interesting doing these
interviews where i can't talk specifics
yet even though i've seen it you know
what i mean it's just the nature of mcu
stuff but thank you so much for your
time and thank you for the series oh
thank you my pleasure have a great day
you too